just how big is the international space
station the largest human-made object in
space
one way to find out is to have it land
on earth in this video we're comparing
the size of space objects to things on
earth so we can really appreciate just
how massive they are the space station
is roughly the length of a football
field for the past two decades over 200
astronauts from 19 countries have lived
and done research on our home away from
home spacex made history in 2020 by
sending astronauts to the iss aboard the
falcon 9. the first private spacecraft
to go into orbit the falcon 9 is 70
meters tall or about 230
feet thankfully i was not incinerated
the falcon 9 launched the dragon capsule
to the space station only four entities
have ever sent a space capsule into
orbit and brought it back to earth the
us russia china and spacex what's
impressive about the falcon 9 is that
the booster returns to earth and can fly
again greatly reducing the cost of space
flight reusable rockets are crucial to
ushering in the age of space tourism and
we're starting to get a glimpse of what
that will look like spacex made history
with the falcon 9 again in september
when it sent the first all-civilian crew
into space this rocket is also being
used in the near future to try to
protect earth from dangerous asteroids
it will carry a piece of nasa technology
that will attempt to slam into an
asteroid's moon the government agency
wants to see if it can change the
trajectory of dimorphous a small moon
orbiting the asteroid didymos which
occasionally comes close to earth
they're testing whether this is a viable
way to prevent a killer asteroid from
colliding with their planet the largest
to pass by earth in 2021 was asteroid
2001 fo 32 how big was it here in
toronto it's comparable to the size of
the cn tower luckily the asteroid passed
us by a safe 1.25 million miles 2
million kilometers away it was big
enough to have done some damage if it
hit and asteroids can be a lot bigger
larger than an entire city 45 eugenia
has a diameter of 133
miles or
214 kilometers in case you don't want to
be around if an asteroid of any
significant size hits earth spacex is
developing starship to take people to
mars
starship is the largest rocket ever the
starship measures 120 meters tall or
nearly 400 feet when the super heavy
booster and the starship spacecraft are
stacked together it's so tall that we
couldn't actually capture the entire
rocket when we panned up so here's
another angle the falcon 9 is barely the
height of the starship's booster the
standout feature of the starship system
is that it's fully reusable here's how
it works
starship is lifted into orbit by the
super heavy booster which then comes
back to earth it meets up with another
starship configured as a tanker in order
to refuel an earth's orbit before making
the long journey to the red planet it
could also fly to the moon in a similar
manner the booster isn't required for
the return since there's no deep gravity
well to escape from on mars starship
flies solo fueled by locally produced
methane the dream is to launch and land
as often as planes fly spacex wants to
use starship as a base to build a city
ceo elon musk has said he thinks there's
nothing more exciting than making life
multi-planetary we've talked a lot about
landing rockets but what about a landing
page which brings me to the sponsor of
my video unbounce let's say you want to
share something with the world a special
offer an event a campaign you're running
a landing page is the best way to get
the message out there it's very
different than a website a website can
have too much information that might be
hard for your audience to find what
they're looking for whereas a landing
page helps focus your message think of a
website as a crowded restaurant with
long wait times compared to a landing
page which is a boutique restaurant with
a private table for your customers a
landing page can help you nab more sales
and sign ups you can even use it to
redirect to your ecommerce site unbounce
has over 100 designs to choose from
there's no coding required whatsoever
you can try it out with my custom link
which is in the description and once you
use my promo code newsthink you'll get
20 off of your first three months thanks
for watching for newsthink i'm cindy
palm